لا اله
[Silence]
السلام عليكم
بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم الحمد لله والصلاه
والسلام على رسول الله اما بعد
فالدرس درس موصول في كتاب الوجيز
في كتاب الطهاره منه في باب وجوب الاقتصاد
في ماء الوضوء وحرمه الاسراف فيه
econom
‏small
prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
make
وضو
‏more
to was each oftimes
this isit
first of all the prop
second of all it is beond the am
necessary
‏made
the sch made in the of
the
make
out of custom
so for instance
‏How many of us make w or even this
morning this morning to come for how
many of us made by pouring water into a
white mouth pot and making from that
white mouth pot and making sure that it
was only about 1 L in volum I would wer
none of us we all
‏Now
turn on the fa and makes
no matter how
careful person is unless they are going
to great links and great pain
they are going to almost always use more
than the prophet
us to
‏So what is on this? Well, this is not
that you are using more out of worship.
‏You are using more water simply because
of the medium that is used to bring the
water to you.
Because the medium has differed the
custom of what is a lot of water and a
little of changed.
And so because of this a person may use
more than the prop صلى الله عليه وسلم
used.
‏However, this is because of custom not
because of worship person
this is how much the prop صلى الله عليه
وسلم and I need more this is this is
different however if person in custom
uses more because of the way thating
work and drains
يقول
المؤلف وقال الله تعالى ولا تسرفوا انه لا
يحب المسرفين الله سبحانه وتعالى
الله
وعن ابي نعامه ان عبد الله
ابن مغفل سمع ابنه يقول اللهم اني اسالك
القصر الابيض عن يمين الجنه اذا دخلتها
اسالك
فيقول عبد الله بن مغفل لابنه اي بني
سال الله الجنه وتعوذ به من النار فاني
سمعت رسول الله صلى الله عليه وسلم يقول
انه سيكون في هذه الامه قوم يعتدون في
الطهور والدعاء والحديث عند ابي داوود في
سننه so here we haveation
of ابي نعامه ابو نعامه
تابعين
عبد الله بن مغفل
making
‏in
quadrant of paradic
my
paradek
fromell
الله صلى الله عليه وسلم
[Silence]
‏inور
وضو غسل
دعاء
ابو داود يقول صاحب عون المعبود
اجمع العلماء على النهي عن الاسراف في
الماء ولو في شاطئ البحر
وهذا الحديث يتناول الغسل والوضوء واذ
ازاله النجاسه
عون المعبود
سن ابي داوود
in
the agon
of wasful of
a person is on
[Silence]
غسل وضو
نسال الله سبحانه وتعالى ان يعفو عنا وان
يغفر لنا ذنوبنا ان يكفر عنا سيئاتنا وان
يهدينا ويهدي بنا والله اعلم وصلى الله
وسلم على نبينا